ええええええ
今回は肇社長ですではエンディング発表会後半行ってみましょう前半ではなかなか
激しい奴がクオリティ高いやつがあったんですけども考案のこんなに立つとに仙台とか
もうほぼ絶景くれてですが連発してちょっとビビったんですけども町と述べる見ていき
ましょう皆
順で良いかねばいこう
俺じゃねぇ
かわいいにつける
うううう
9分
いいねぇ
ああああああ
どんびりして良いと思いますこういう思うん
う
なんか
嫌なことでもあった惚れちゃうければ相談に乗るよん
作用素です
だった
やめろやめろやめの黒歴史だなぁん
うん
あっはっは
まあニートもステージ素敵どんどんいきますよ
ふぅ
うんはすげえなこれとか
うわぁ
もうここはネギとすごいんですよねーうーん
ドア
母
あー出てるよ
これすごいですよあの俺の集めて住んでた部屋
次に住んでた部屋これ今まで出来れ部屋なんて全部これが今住んで部屋
これをフリーでつっていううーん
ローすごいゲーム感がファミコン感がある
ふぉわーずぜぞいあまずは2のテレポート使って失敗した時の黒くなった時のあれです
次
rono ん
おっ
もうああはだけですが
は俺の金髪の時のと思ったら所沢出てきてハンマーで叩き割って
俺だいやーもうせませんあの後半はただただすごい道が続きますこんな感じでいきます
よ
がすごいよのど黒であ
飛んでいくんだ山陽ぴ
梅みんなに行為濃い濃い濃い
メニーメニー
ネイビーなになになにこれ
ただザホラーズ次行きましょう
なにこれ
かっこええ
スポーツゲー
オサレだなぁとして個人的なんですけどとンドってすごい好きでしたね
うん
なんならこのなんか煽る圧迫感のある bgm
これアイコンよく見たら俺じゃないこれ品やんけ平壌県これでしょそう
ありがとう
釜山よ
某幅えええ
すげーすげー
すごいイラストがかわいい
をやったーーーーー燃やす+も破るうわぁ全部美味しいじゃんクオリティ高いからねぇ
俺はきたすごいのえっ
ま自分ぞ
大瀬件さすがは2分ちゃん
どんどん行けますよ後半戦ですよ
ピントが合ってきたあああ
わー
1分28秒もあるのねちょ最後だけ家になるで最後だけみようか
積んだの
大
口が動いてるん
おおーー
誰
おおああああもうちょっとアナああああ次
おいやめろをやるときなきゃやらなきゃ女
やら親もそうだもすんじゃないわ
魔女頃なんてちょっとねえ俺のエンディングじゃないでしょ
次
大所沢な
本日は所沢です
みんなちょっと好きねぇ
4をかじってるか競ってるさせてる俺がかしてるよ
すごいふっ
めっちゃ可愛いんですけど
うわぁ
これ好きかも
まあかわいい
次イラストなもうかなり補正されてますねはかわいい
これもすげーなー
すごいよアイコンがまずは2バージョンをはじめだ
ん
違う車俺じゃないよね
おぬね3やばいやばいよこれは
所沢だなくすごいなぁ
うーんうわぁやばいよ
うごっちゃに乗ってるん
かわいいいぇーい
有無は関係なのだこれが多いのが好きな人だ
うおおーおーすげー4
みずみずしいいよいよ最後のほうです
どーん
開いた口がふさがらないというのはこういうことなのだろうか
どうでもすごい
素敵なありがとうございます人のうち4さん
うえええああっにも衣装勢い
やめとけやん
4大洗でられている
もう可愛い
かわいい
うん
わー
だがば運賃こそその姉はやるだけやいえ石田さん
6そして
ねえウールん
範囲テレビでエンディング全部見終わりました音とおつかれさまでしたありがとう
ございました
これ以外にも本当にたくさんのエンディングを作ってくれました
気楽に作ってくれたんだなっていうのはあるしすごい時間かけて行ってくれたんだなっ
て思ったのもあったしすごく大勢の皆様に応援されているなということを改めて実感し
ました
本当にいつもありがとうございます毎日動画でエンディング帰って行ってもいいの
かなと思う
たんですよせっかく皆さん作ってくれたんであんですけどやっぱりリングは僕は一つで
いきたいなと思っているので今回会ったこの全てのエンディングの中が一つだけ使わせ
ていただきますではしばらくはこのエンディングでいこうと思いますエンディングが
やっと一段落したので質問コーナーまた時間あればやろうかなと思っております
では次回の動画でお会いしましょうじゃん
このエンディング
me
あっ